[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ce lundi 28 octobre très
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
sur tv 78 voici les titres de ce journal
les travaux du tram 13 express se
poursuivent en 2021 la ligne doit relier
en 30 minutes sans cyr l'école à saint
germain en laye ce matin une visite du
chantier se tenait dans la ville saint
germanoise où les premiers rails du
tramway ont été posées il est encore
temps de vous inscrire dans quatre jours
c'est le début du mois sans tabac un
défi collectif pour arrêter de fumer en
novembre présent sur trois sites dans le
département
le centre de soins d'accompagnement et
de prévention en addictologie vous
accompagne dans l' aventure et puis
c'est confirmé attrape la majorité de
gauche partira bien diviser pour les
municipales face au maire sortant guy
malandain l'adjoint ali rabais sera
également tête de liste il a lancé sa
campagne jeudi en compagnie de benoît
hamon
mais on débute ce journal tout de suite
par cette visite au château de
versailles
aujourd'hui près de 200 personnes plus
de 100 personnes ont été accueillies
dans la demeure des rois de france des
familles des groupes d'enfants des
seniors des personnes isolées et aussi
des migrants avec des visites et
activités durant toute la journée une
initiative du secours populaire des
yvelines on en parle avec vous allez me
grillon soir à vous êtes secrétaire
départemental à la fédération des
yvelines du secours populaire français
déjà une première question pourquoi
organiser cette visite aujourd'hui au
château de versailles
alors en fait on a un partenariat que
celle de versailles depuis le début des
années 2000 et le souhait du secours
populaire c'est de développer et de
favoriser l'accès à la culture
donc en fait on souhaite notamment par
la journée d'aujourd'hui avoir une étape
et développer davantage l'accès à la
culture pour les pluies qu'on reçoit
que ce soit au château de versailles ou
ailleurs et on l'a pu aujourd'hui
bénéficier de
ateliers proposés par le château compte
avant l'après midi autour tout ce qui
est donc ce dorures et théâtre c'était
pâques de la visite il y avait des
ateliers d actualité sur place qui était
proposé aussi en complément de la visite
de ce matin et pour tout de suite le
public comme vous l'avez dit sur les
familles les seniors les airs les
personnes isolées les non sens donc un
accès la culture dans cette vitrine
culturelle qu'est le château de
versailles dans les yvelines où on
écoute d'ailleurs tout de suite quelques
enfants 1 qui ont participé à cette
sortie aujourd'hui on visite on regarde
les oeuvres on comprend en fait tu toi
tu
j'aime moins de théâtre j'en ai déjà
fait ce matin la visite est le château
la visiter la salle nice albert houngbo
on a visité la chambre du roi dans la
ligne lyon vient de voir des enfants
mais vous l'avez dit différent aux
différentes personnes qui ont pu
assister aujourd'hui à cette visite fait
élever des enfants leurs familles des
seniors des migrants et des personnes
isolées de toutes les yvelines
originaire de plusieurs villes des
yvelines et qui on avait fait les
inscriptions là non pour qu'il vienne
aujourd'hui voilà du coup le bilan de la
journée les familles et les enfants
étaient contents
tous sont revenus enchantés et vraiment
on espère que par ce biais là de cette
initiative qu'on a pu faire aujourd'hui
qu'on puisse développer davantage
l'accès à la culture pour les publics on
reçoit pour lord démontré que l'accès à
l'écriture c'est aussi pour eux et pas
pour les autres mais voilà pour cette
visite aujourd'hui au château de
versailles le secours populaire a tenu
aussi tout récemment son congrès
départemental pascal rodier a été
reconduit comme secrétaire général à la
tête de la fédération jusqu'en 2021 vous
avez été reconduite secrétaire
départemental quel est le bilan des
actions justement mener sur ces deux ans
la dernière mandature c'était 2017 2019
quel quel bilan vous tirer alors on
tient un bilan en fait
sur le sur la dernière mandature en fait
2017 2019 où on l'a développé des
actions eon soit développée sur les
années à venir les actions pour les
jeunes pourquoi pas pour les enfants
copains du monde aussi et on a pu aussi
montré par le biais de nos actions sur
les axes les années passées là la
présence est là l'importance aussi des
deux publics tels que les migrants qui
sont de plus en plus apparu en fait à
nouveau d'actualité au niveau du
scrupule air sont notamment sur le
département et on souhaite aussi sur les
années à venir développer nos actions
sur les actions de solidarité mondiale
non plus et accroître annoncé d'action
là de deux projets à l'étranger aussi
d'ailleurs la solidarité mondiale crois
que ce sera le prochain thème des
prochaines du prochain congrès pardon
national du secours populaire place et
donc en fait le congrès départemental ne
faisait qu' on t'a mais la perspective
des travaux de travaux en fait tout
court est la seule qui aura lieu en
novembre justement et vous le disiez
davantage de personnes accueillies enfin
qui ont bénéficié du secours populaire
notamment les migrants s'est de plus de
neuf mille bénéficiaires aujourd'hui du
secours populaire ont cédé sur le
département n'a effectivement neuf mille
bénéficiaires qui
s'ils viennent régulièrement nous voir
pour des z que ceux d aide matérielle
alimentaire vestimentaire mais aussi
tout ce qu'ils aient accès aux loisirs
vacances aux sorties comme on a pu le
voir aujourd'hui et donc du coup c'est
tout un public qu'on rencontre toute
l'année au salon d'accueil et du coup je
précise juste que cette date 1 on
parlait du congrès national du secours
populaire français qui se tiendra les 15
16 et 17 novembre à perpignan sur le
thème je le disais de la solidarité
internationale merci à lille 0 1 est
repassé en plateau je rappelle que vous
êtes là la secrétaire départemental du
secours populaire des yvelines est la
pose des premières infrastructures du
tram t 13 la future ligne reliant saint
germain en laye à saint-cyr-l'ecole
entre dans une phase de concrétisation
est les premiers à y ont été installés
dans la ville saint germanoise les
détails de nicolas landry sur des images
de manon varaldo les premiers rails du
tram traits sont arrivés à saint germain
en laye il ya maintenant un peu plus
d'un mois la pause a commencé depuis la
station rer a jusqu'à la gare de saint
germain grande ceinture des travaux
prévus sur près de quatre kilomètres
durant un an
donc cette pose de voix se réaliser et
réalisé sur une plateforme béton pause
classique nous avons en premier coulage
de béton pose de rails un deuxième
collège de béton et on viendra ensuite
une troisième étape de coulage qui
définira le niveau définitif du tramway
de plusieurs zones de travaux l'avenue
des loges l'avenue du président kennedy
ou encore la rn184 d axe très fréquenté
par les automobilistes
on peut aussi avoir des contraintes qui
sont propres projets par exemple du fait
de traverser des routes importantes
c'est le cas de la rn184 et de la rd 190
du côté de l'allée des loges on impact
aussi la rd 105 ans est donc aux limites
extrêmement les impacts sur la
circulation routière
restera ensuite la pose du mobilier la
réalisation des stations avec les
premiers essais en 2021
le projet final prévoit de relier saint
germain en laye à saint cyr l'école en
passant par mareil marly et noisy le roi
un parcours de 19 km coût total de
l'infrastructure 306 millions d'euros
mise en service prévue à la fin de
l'année 2021 en france le tabac est
responsable de 73 mille décès par an
dont 45 milles par cancer sans tabac on
estime que près d'un tiers des décès par
cancer
justement pourraient être évités arrêter
de fumer c'est le défi lancé en novembre
avec le mois sans tabac pour en parler
le docteur claire farina bonsoir vous
êtes au psychiatre addictologue haut
avec ça pas à trappes et versailles
alors le que ça passe et le centre de
soins et d'accompagnement et de
prévention en addictologie qui est
rattachée au centre hospitalier andré
mignot à versailles il est présent dans
les yvelines à trappes à versailles est
aussi à rambouillet alors le mois sans
tabac ça avant tout un défi collectif
c'est ça tout à fait c'est l'occasion de
se lancer dans cette belle aventure
qu'est la libération du tabac et on
s'engage le plus de personnes possible à
participer car plus on essaye d'arrêter
et plus on a de chances qu'ils arrivent
mais à cette heure ci alors je vous
parle 10 18 heures passées à peu près
cent vingt-cinq mille 1 500 personnes se
sont déjà inscrites sur le site internet
du mois sans tabac c'est un mois ou si
le soutien des proches est très
important on n'arrête pas seul tout à
fait plus on a de soutien et plus on a
de gens extérieurs qui nous soutiennent
et plus ça fonctionne effective
encourager vos proches pourquoi arrêter
de fumer ou peut-être plutôt comment y
parvenir
ce qu'il faut être motivé est ce que
c'est le maître mot la motivation
la motivation est effectivement très
importantes alors il ya deux questions
pourquoi parce que plus on arrête de
fumer tôt et moi on aura de problèmes
qui sont liés au tabac donc par exemple
si on arrête de fumer à 30 ans on sait
qu'à 40 on a un risque cardiovasculaire
qui va quasiment évalue à celui des non
fumeurs même si on arrête de fumer plus
tard on aura des bénéfices pour sa santé
que ce soit sur le plan psychique ou
physique
que ce soit au niveau cardiovasculaire
cancer et cetera donc il ya toujours un
bénéfice à arrêter de fumer y compris
quand on est déjà souffrent parce que le
pronostic l'évolution de la maladie sera
mieux si on est libéré du tabac et
comment arrêter de fumer donc déjà on
peut le décider et arrêter du jour au
lendemain c'est tout à fait possible et
il ya la dépendance au tabac ces trois
choses c'est la dépendance à la nicotine
pour laquelle il ya des médicaments les
substituts nicotiniques on connaît les
patchs et caetera et à la dépendance
psychologique je suis stressée je
consomme une cigarette
je suis stressée je pourrais faire autre
chose et peut-être j'ai d'autres
éléments que je pourrais travailler et à
la dépendance comportementale donc le
fait qu'on est habitué à consommer dans
telle ou telle situation et ça c'est
quelque chose qui peut se travailler
aussi
ceci est important de savoir pourquoi on
doit arrêter de se poser la question de
réfléchir à pourquoi pourquoi arrêter
il ya des gens qui arrêtent du jour au
lendemain sans aucune raison et c'est
très bien aussi donc qu'on ait une
raison ou pas arrêter c'est très bien
c'est bien pour sa santé pour ses
proches
le tabagisme passif ça tue aussi même si
bien évidemment c'est parce que la
personne souhaite quand elle quand elle
fume on sait par exemple que depuis
qu'on a enlevé l'autorisation de fumer
dans les lieux publics
on a une diminution du taux d'infarctus
du myocarde qui est liée à la diminution
du tabagisme passif
donc c'est tout le monde d'arrêter de
fumer donc vous le disais il ya des de
réel effet sur des bénéfices à arrêter
de fumer
oui très rapide d'ailleurs pour le mois
sans tabac pour les participants
il ya une petite enveloppe où il ya
plein de choses il ya un site web qui
est très bien fait pour le mois sans
tabac on peut s'inscrire comme vous
l'avez très justement dit tout à l'heure
vous avez aussi tabac info service
80 39 89 et dans ce petit dans ce petit
calendrier vous verrez jour après jour
les bénéfices que vous avez à arrêter le
tabac
il ya des bénéfices très rapide en 24
heures il y en a qui sont un peu plus
lointain il y en a qui sont très
lointain ils sont tous bons à prendre
mais c'est ça il ya un kit pour les
personnes qui participent au mois sans
tabac avec un accompagnement aussi on
peut être accompagné par mail
appelez le 39 89 tabac info service
tout à fait tout est possible en
s'inscrivant sur le site vous aurez
toutes les modalités possibles de suivi
que ce soit par mail que ce soit par
téléphone
vous pouvez aussi venu nous voir en
auxois pas et on a aussi des
interventions où nous on va promouvoir
donc ce mois sans tabac à l'extérieur
mais d'ailleurs je vais vous demander
comment le sapin s'associe à cet
événement est ce qu'il ya des animations
des événements organisés à l'occasion du
mois sans tabac fait donc des collègues
seront présents à versailles au niveau
de la place de la mairie sur une journée
le 13 novembre nous mêmes on sera
présent le 7 novembre à la gare de saint
quentin le matin et le soir et donc il y
aura différentes différentes
interventions dans ce dans le cadre de
ce mois dans le cadre du moins sans
tabac on en termine par le ca pas si
vous pouviez nous présenter en quelques
mots ce qu'est loxapac admission et et
qui composent
justement le look sympa donc le qs a
passé un an comme vous l'avez dit c'est
un lieu de soins le nôtre dépend de
l'hôpital mignot c'est un centre de
soins où vous avez médecins assistantes
sociales infirmiers psychologues
secrétaire tout un tout une équipe qui
est là pour aider les gens à arrêter ce
qu'il souhaite mettre à distance ça peut
être le tabac ça peut aussi être une
dépendance comportementale ça peut être
différentes choses
l'alcool la cocaïne on reçoit tout type
de personnes on reçoit aussi les
entourages des gens qui sont confrontés
à la difficulté d'une addiction sans la
vivre eux mêmes et donc tout est gratuit
et anonyme au niveau des que ça passe
je sais vous intervenez vous a attrapé
versailles mais aussi une antenne à
rambouillet il ya aussi une antenne à
rambouillet rambouillet et trappes et
versailles vous serez reçus par trois
équipes qui sont charpente en quelques
en quelques secondes pourquoi participer
au mois sans tabac parce que ça augmente
les chances d'arrêter de fumer on a cinq
fois plus de chances d'arrêter de fumer
et c'est très belles occasions et en
plus comme c'est un challenge collectif
on est tous ensemble dans le même dans
le même bateau venez nous voir encore
s'inscrire le mois sans tabac débute le
1er novembre merci claire farina ses
emplettes au psychiatre addictologue
addictologue par mohawk sapa et je
rappelle un look ça passe et le centre
de soins d'accompagnement et de
prévention en addictologie et vous
intervenez vous à versailles être apte
merci d'être passé en plateau l es
rencontres autour du siaap continue
cette station d'épuration prenait feu le
3 juillet dernier à achères responsable
du site représentants de l'état élus
locaux se retrouvaient à nouveau en fin
de semaine dernière pour faire le point
une réunion en préfecture de versailles
cette fois ci et en présence de la
secrétaire d'état à la transition
écologique mélanie poker et les réunions
s'enchaînent pour les principaux
concernés de l' incendie du siaap
une nouvelle rencontre s'est tenue cette
fois en préfecture de versailles à huis
clos en présence de la secrétaire d'état
la transition écologique
trois axes de travail une meilleure
information association des riverains
des habitants un travail sur la sécurité
du site avec un audit externe et une
maîtrise du process de reconstruction et
de de qualité des eaux et de limitation
du risque à déverser des eaux dans la
seine est donc avoir de la mortalité
piscicole d'ici à l'été prochain
il y a trois mois un incendie se
déclarait à la station d'épuration
d'achères impliquant une forte pollution
de la senne un audit réclamé dès juillet
débutera à la mi novembre
l'audi doit nous permettent de voir les
choses qu' on n'a pas perçu ou
on n'a pas détecté et qui vont faire le
point sur les les faiblesses éventuelles
existe il faudra tout de suite et
renforcée par attendre la fin de l'audit
qui elle aura lieu à la fin du premier
trimestre on a précisé que le siaap avec
les étapes intermédiaires au mois de
juin on sera en capacité d'avoir un
fonctionnement identique à celui de 2016
avant la livraison de nouvelles
installations en 2017 une sixième
réunion est prévue pour la mi-décembre
en sous-préfecture de
saint-germain-en-laye
une rencontre entre les riverains et la
secrétaire d'état pourrait se tenir
courant novembre
la visite des manuels wargon qui
s'ajoute un double déplacement
ministériel vendredi dans les yvelines
gabriel attal et laurent gogniat c'était
au camp de ben
les secrétaires d'état auprès du
ministre de l'éducation nationale et du
ministre de l'intérieur rencontrer des
jeunes volontaires du service national
universel
pendant toutes les vacances de la
toussaint ils sont en mission d'intérêt
général auprès de la gendarmerie
nationale est deuxième phase de test
pour le fmi qui doit d'être qui doit
être généralisé avant 2026 2000 jeunes y
participent dans toute la france et
laurent nunez a poursuivi son
déplacement seul dans les yvelines
visite au commissariat de trappes pour
évoquer notamment les questions de
sécurité sur le territoire attrape
injustement les élections municipales se
prépare comme partout dans les yvelines
et en france
un scrutin pour lequel la majorité
partir à diviser ali rappelle l'adjointe
à la jeunesse et aux sports est candidat
sa campagne électorale a été lancée
jeudi dernier des valeurs de gauche et
un programme qu'il souhaite construire
avec les habitants nicolas landry pour
que tu rappes respire c'est le nom de la
liste conduite par ali rabais pour les
élections municipales de 2020 une
campagne lancée auprès de benoît hamon
et alain degois fondateur de déclic
théâtre tous deux engagés auprès d'al
hira b l'adjoint délégué à la jeunesse
et aux sports se détache du maire guy
malandain
sans renier son bilan au sein de la
majorité municipale beaucoup a été fait
pour transformer les murs de trappes
rechange et les squares les rues de
trappes
guy malandain fait un très bon travail
mais au terme de vingt ans de mandat
j'estime qu'il est temps de transmettre
le témoin et qu'il est temps qu'on
s'occupe maintenant des habitants plus
encore que des bâtiments
parce qu'il faut réussir la
transformation de la ville de trappes on
a réussi sa transformation urbaine
il faut réussir sa transformation
humaine j'estime que être candidat à 83
ans n'est pas raisonnable je les dis à
guy malandain
je me sens libre donc de m'engager dans
une campagne pour proposer une dynamique
nouvelle
une énergie nouvelle mobilisation des
trappistes pour continuer le travail
engagé
la campagne est axée sur quatre
thématiques l'environnement et le
développement durable l'éducation et le
parcours scolaire l'économie locale et
l'engagement citoyen avec un programme
co construit avec les habitants j'ai
constaté que j'étais bien meilleur que
les projets portés par la municipalité
était beaucoup plus efficace il visait
juste quand il associe étroitement les
habitants pour la construction du
programme lui-même
je ne vais pas me contenter de réfléchir
dans mon coin avec mon équipe
j'irai en porte à porte en pied
d'immeuble dans les réunions
d'appartement en réunion publique
demandez aux trappistes leur avis sur
les propositions que je porte des
discussions entre alliés arabes et luc
miserez représentants du mouvement
d'opposition trappe à gauche sont en
cours
l'actuel maire guy malandain a déjà
annoncé sa candidature comme othman
nassr ou associé à mustapha larbaoui les
élections auront lieu le 15 et 22 mars
prochains
[Musique]
comme chaque lundi les principaux
résultats sportifs du week-end c'est
avec vous mais quel ennemi d' eurobonds
soir dans sa grille analystes sport de
la rédaction tv 78 du football pour
commencer avec une rencontre très locale
un derby heavy noir match en retard de
d2 de district guyancourt recevez
villepreux une rencontre qui commence
fort après seulement deux minutes de jeu
les gluants courtois marque par
l'intérêt de l'intermédiaire de
l'attaquant aurait avancé
cueillis à froid les villes prose y
encaissent un deuxième but moins de cinq
minutes plus tard par l'inévitable or et
diamants ces matches ne s'arrangent pas
pour les visiteurs troisième but sur 63
à 0 ce sera le score à la mi-temps en
deuxième période ville proulx se
ressaisit poussent pour revenir dans le
match mais les joueurs de patrick et
dominguez sont maladroits dans le
dernier geste ce sont finalement les
gluons courtois qui inscriront le
dernier but de la partie en contre
score final 4 à 0 on a maîtrisé le mois
du début à la fin on mène 3-0 quand même
au bout d'une demi heure de jeu donc
c'est quand même un signe d'une bonne
maîtrise pourquoi je suis satisfait du
match qu'on a fait surtout qu'on sortait
de deux revers très dur on a pris deux
fois 3-0
donc c'est important de se rassurer
défensivement et faire du bien au groupe
dans les têtes
au classement guyancourt remonte il se
retrouve septième de son côté à
villepreux et désormais lanterne rouge
de ce championnat avec un seul nul
depuis le début de la saison ça commence
à être inquiétant prochain match le
dimanche 10 novembre du en cours recevra
l'équipe 2 de trappes et villepreux
accueillera houdan nous voilà pour le
clin d'oeil locale ce derby saint
quentinois y avait aussi de la coupe de
france ce week-end en football ont joué
ce week-end le 6e tour déjà versailles
dernier représentant yvelinois dans la
compétition a eu très chaud face à viry
châtillon et versailles est classé une
division au dessus de leurs adversaires
en nationale 3 sont allés s'imposer
après une stressante séance de tirs au
but après avoir concédé le match nul et
vierge
il emporte 5 à 4 un résultat qui leur
suffit à se hisser au septième tour
comme la saison dernière
le rendez-vous sera programmée le 17
novembre prochain avec l'entrée des
clubs de ligue 2 et du rugby aussi dans
les yvelines en fédérale 2 a plaisir à
réaliser une belle opération ce week-end
lors de la 6e journée les hommes de
sébastien roncalli se sont imposés sur
la pelouse de l'amicale sarcelles ce
dimanche le score 22 à 14
une victoire qui permet aux plaisirs wa
de monter à la huitième place
saint-pierre bilan de 2 victoires 1 nul
et 3 défaites en écoute l'entraîneur de
l'équipe
ce résultat effectivement il était
capital pour essayer de se projeter vers
ce milieu de tableau à voir la
qualification maintenant
le prochain bloc va être déterminant
leur blé d'europe 1 dimanche ma
charrette et après on a trois matches
dont deux à domicile sur des mêmes
niveaux clés au classement du rugby
encore avec le championnat de fédérale 3
lors de la 6e journée vers celle promue
cette année dans la division a réalisé
une très belle performance à domicile en
s'imposant sur son terrain contre ou
dans le derby yvelinois le score est
sans appel 46 à 17
un résultat qui fait leur bonheur les
verser entre dans le top 5 de leur poule
avec un bilan de 3 victoires 1 nul et 2
défaites depuis le début de la saison
merci michael ces résultats bien
d'autres encore aussi des annonces de
rencontres des reportages dans votre
émission de 7,8 sport et c'est à
retrouver bien sûr après ce journal sur
tv 78 avant de vous laisser une
sculpture installée à guyancourt
vendredi une commande de la mairie mais
aussi des habitants elles sont une
dizaine de commanditaires en tout à
l'avoir a sélectionné dans un catalogue
d'artistes reportage de patrick jacques
de dixmude et 2 me et 2 mathilde et demi
deux ans de travail vingtaine de granit
sont déplacés aujourd'hui dans le
quartier du pont du route voire à
guyancourt l'oeuvre de grégory gicquel
et daniel dewar a été sélectionné par
les nouveaux commanditaires de
guyancourt les nouveaux commanditaires
est un processus organisé par la
fondation de france qui permet donc un
financement fondation de france bien sûr
mais aussi avec une médiatrice de
pouvoir discuter de créer un cahier des
charges et à ce moment là de développer
le projet avec les différents
partenaires donc bien sûr la ville les
habitants
et puis nous on a aussi des mécènes et
des mêmes des commerçants qui en
participer à ce projet nathalie
habitants du quartier à participer au
projet et à la commande de la sculpture
contacté par la mairie
elle a accepté d'être une des
commanditaires pour le patrimoine de sa
ville
nous avons eu différentes réunions où
nous a expliqué le principe de la
commande faite par des habitants auprès
d'artistes
et c'est quelque chose auquel nous
sommes pas familier en tout cas pour ma
part je n'étais pas et j'ai trouvé ça
très intéressant d'autant plus que nous
y étions accompagnés par une médiatrice
anxieux mais ravis de pouvoir installer
son oeuvre intitulée le rocher le lièvre
et le banc grégory gicquel a respecté le
cahier des charges avec son
collaborateur pour que la sculpture se
fondent dans le quartier nous avons
proposé un projet on a eu un cahier des
charges qui était axé un peu sur la
nature sur l'histoire de guyancourt
donc on leur a proposé cette oeuvre qui
est complètement lié aussi à notre
propre travail
une oeuvre qui se voulait utile grâce
aux dons inclus mais aussi agréable
visuellement la sculpture respecte donc
les envies des habitants du quartier qui
vont pouvoir à présent l'admirer de plus
près et on met le cap à montigny le
bretonneux pour refermer ce journal la
ville accueillait ce week-end un
rendez-vous d'échec le 18e tournoi
d'automne organisé par la dame noire le
club local de la ville
le principe des groupes de dix
participants se sont affrontés pendant
l'événement quelles sont les recettes
pour remporter la victoire aux échecs
l'un des organisateurs au micro de manu
varaldo ce qu'il faut de la
concentration et bien s'entraîner
régulièrement parce que ça paraît pas
mais c'est quand même physiquement
éprouvante
même si on est assis transpire des
neurones quand même voilà c'est la fin
de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
replay sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 j'aurai le
plaisir de vous retrouver dès demain
pour une nouvelle édition du journal
d'actualités locales belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]